la pandémie de coronavirus pourrait
rebattre les cartes au sahel
si l'on en croit certains observateurs
le niger
jusqu'ici épargnée enregistre ses
premières victimes du coc vie de 10,9 au
moins un mort ce jeudi et une dizaine
d'oeufs contaminés
ce vendredi le président de la
république a proclamé l'état d'urgence
sanitaire mais aussi 1500 remise de
peine pour les détenus les plus âgées en
particulier un couvre-feu de deux
semaines est également instauré dans la
capitale niamey instauration à niamey
seules villes touchées par le virus d'un
coureur de 19 heures à 6 heures du matin
plus il ya de bons semaine renouvelable
à compter du samedi 28 mars 2020
4 il commence à des thèmes ou la ville
de niamey prévu durée de deux semaines
au mali voisin deux cas de décès sont
connus de manière rapatriés de france à
la mi mars
depuis mercredi tout le pays applique un
couvre feu les élections législatives
prévues ce dimanche sont pourtant
maintenu en pleine campagne le chef de
file de l'opposition soumaïla cissé a
été enlevé
malheureusement au cours des opérations
d'enlèvement
parce qu'en fait ils ont été enlevés par
un groupe armé
nous ne connaissons pas leur identité
ceux des hommes armés pour nous non
encore identifié jusque là il faut être
clair la semaine dernière un autre
candidat et son équipe avaient été
retenus pendant 48 heures le même jour
l'armée malienne subissait une attaque
terroriste au moins 30 soldats tués
lundi au tchad
plus de 100 militaires ont trouvé la
mort dans une attaque du groupe
terroriste boko haram
l'armée tchadienne est pourtant
considérée comme la meilleure des pays
de la zone
d'après des analystes dont l'institut de
veille et d'études des relations
internationales et stratégiques
la crise du coronavirus contribuerait
par ailleurs à l'affaiblissement de
l'opération française barkan au sahel
l'opération d'une envergure inédite avec
5000 hommes mobilisés menée ce mois-ci
au mali au niger a permis d'éliminer un
grand nombre de terroristes déclaration
de l'état major français ce samedi
s